PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
CALL THE NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC CLOSELY
THERE'S AN EMPLOYEE'S. WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN IT HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES OF ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CURES MANY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. TODAY'S SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME
TO BE DETERMINED BY THE CHAIR
IN THE HAS BEEN DETERMINED. ME
WITNESSES WERE OF TWO MINUTES.
FOR EACH ITNESS AND THERE IS
NO RESERVING TIME FOR OTHER
WITNESSES. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
PROMISE TO NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES. FOR
THESE WITNESSES THERE WILL BE A
LIMIT OF TEN MINUTES FOR
SUPPORT. IN TEN MINUTES FOR
OPPOSITION. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS. WOULD MOVE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALL
WHILE. IT WILL BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS TESTIFIED
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. HE WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE. AGAIN.
877-692-8953 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX NINE
ZERO NINE. AGAIN ACCESS CODE.
SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX NINE ZERO
NINE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECOM SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. FOR
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. REMOVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION PURPOSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU ONE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER HE WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOU MY NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE A MUTED. ANYWHERE THEN
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE- MEETING
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. INDIVIDUALS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
FOR EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE OFTEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. WE HAVE FIVE BILLS ON
CONSENT. FOR WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS LET'S
US LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM-
COMPOSITE CONSOLE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CENTER PROTESTING.
COURTESY HERE SENATOR TROUBLES
HERE BUT TROUBLED HERE CENTER
ADDRESS ALL. NOT SO HERE
SENATOR LAYERED- LAYERED HIS
CENTER LEFT HERE NEWMAN. NEWMAN
HERE. THE THANK YOU MENTAL
CONSULTANTS- BEFORE WE GO ANY
FURTHER I WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN WILL BE
PRESENTING HER BILL AB EIGHT
TWENTY SIX OUT OF ORDER WILL GO
FIRST TODAY- FOR REASONS. THAT
WERE PRESENTED EARLIER AND
AGREED TO BY THE CHAIR AFTER
HER PRESENTATION WE WILL GO
BACK TO HERE IN THE BILLS AND
FOLLOW ORDERS. I'D LIKE TO TAKE
OF THE CONSENT ITEMS NOW. THEY
WOULD BE AB TEN THIRTY THREE AB
TWELVE NINETY THREE AB TEN
FORTY EIGHT A. B. THREE
THIRTEEN M. A. B. ONE TEN
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE CONSENT
AGENDA THANK YOU SENATOR BAIRD
WE HAVE A MOTION- ANALYST
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CONSENT ITEMS AGAIN ARE A. B.
TEN THIRTY THREE AB TWELVE
NINETY THREE AB TEN FORTY EIGHT
AB THREE ONE THREE AND AB ONE
TEN THE MOTION IS CONSENT.
SENATOR PROTESTING HI OR DOES
THE AYE BUT CHOI BOGUE I A
TROUBLED BY THE WRESTLE. THE
REST OF I LAYERED HI LAYERED
AYE NEWMAN. NEWMAN NINE. THE
ITEM IS OUT OF FIVE TWO ZERO.
NOW ON TO AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN IF YOU
READY YOU MAY- YOU MAY
COMMENCE- IS IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- EXCEPT IN
THE COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS UNDER OPTION TO SET
UP THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
DISCUSSIONS AMONGST THE
COMMITTEE AND YOUR STUFF IN THE
SPONSORS. IN JUST BEFORE YOU
START TO PRESENT A LET ME
SUMMARIZE MY UNDERSTANDING
THOSE AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY TO
ENSURE THAT IN ORDER TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE LEGACY MEMBERS
PENSION CALCULATION THE
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE MUST HAVE
MADE PENSION CONTRIBUTIONS ON
THE APPLICABLE REMUNERATION
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
MUNICH REMUNERATION WAS IN THE
TWENTY THIRTEEN. TO TWENTY
TWENTY PERIOD FOR THE POST JULY
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY PERIOD-
IN ADDITION IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING- IN YOURS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT- THAT THE BILL'S
AFFECT ON OTHER THIRTY SEVEN X.
SYSTEMS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
IS AN ISSUE AND YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THE BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD TO STRESS WAS CONCERNED
TO SET. SOUND ACCURATE PORTRAIT
YES THAT IS ACCURATE AND WE
DON'T THINK IT'S AN ISSUE WE
DON'T THINK THERE IS THERE ARE
ANY OTHER- A UNITS THAT WOULD
BE AFFECTED BY THIS. WILL PROVE
CRUCIAL. WE WILL- FIVE THE
APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING THAT ON
THE RECORD IN CONTINUING TO- TO
BE MINDFUL OF THAT IN
APPRECIATE- OF YOU PUTTING THE
MEMBERS ON THE RECORD SO THANK
YOU AND NOW YOU MAY PROCEED.
VERY MUCH- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COSPONSORED BY
SEIU CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTY
OF VENTURA AB EIGHT TWO SIX IS
A NARROWLY CRAFTED BILL THAT
WILL ENSURE SPECIFIED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES HIRED PRIOR TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY THIRTEEN.
DO NOT HAVE THEIR PENSIONS
UNFAIRLY REDUCED BY CLARIFYING
THE DEFINITION OF COMPENSATION
OF ALL THE COMPENSATION HERBAL
CONSISTENT WITH PEPPER AND
STANDING LEGAL PRECEDENT THIS
IS A DISTRICT BILL THAT HAS
FULL BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AND IT
SEEKS TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE
AFFECTING LEGACY EMPLOYEES AND
VENTURA COUNTY THAT RECEIVE A
FLEXIBLE BENEFIT ALLOWANCE OR
AN FBA. THIS COMPENSATION IS
PAID EVERY PAY PERIOD TO EVERY
ELIGIBLE EMPLOYEE TO HELP COVER
HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUMS AND
THE BENEFIT IS FULLY FUNDED
THIS BILL DOES NOT CREATE NEW
OR ANTICIPATED COSTS AS BOTH
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES HAVE
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
THEIR PLAN CONTRIBUTIONS. THE
REASON ALAMEDA DECISION BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT DID
NOT SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
SITUATIONS LIKE FTA BUT THE
ARGUMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT
ARGUMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE
QUESTIONING WHETHER VENTURA
COUNTY'S FTA FALLS OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE OF PERMITTED FORMS OF
COMPENSATION. WITHOUT THIS
MODEST CLARIFICATION TO
EXISTING LAW THE LOWEST PAID
EMPLOYEES RISK LOSING UP 210%
OF THEIR MONTHLY PENSION INCOME
WHICH WOULD BE DISASTROUS TO
RETIREES WHO HAVE BUDGETED AND
PLANNED THEIR LIVES AROUND
THEIR EXPECTED PENSION AMOUNT.
TESTIFYING TODAY SUPPORT TERRY
BROWN ART FROM S. C. I. K. S.
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA AND MIKE
POWERS CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FOR THE COUNTY OF INTERNET AND
WE ALSO HAVE AMY GARDNER AN
ATTORNEY FROM VENTURA COUNTY.
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK SO REMEMBER
OWN. BUT VERY HARD TO SEE THAT
WE HAVE- TERRY BRENNAN WILL BE
TESTIFYING. IN IS A TRUE
MICHAEL POWERS ALSO BECAUSE
FIND. VERY PLEASE PROCEED A
MUCH WOULD SELF IDENTIFY AND
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS TERRY BRENNAN ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID A GREAT JOB
OF PRESENTING THE BILL IN THE
NEED FOR THE BILL- I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE CLEAR THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL. THAT
REINTERPRETED SUMMER INTERFERES
WITH THE CAPRA- BILL OF- TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AFFECTED TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN. IT'S MERELY
A CLARIFICATION TO ENSURE THAT
THIS BENEFIT CAN CONTINUE
HAPPENING IT'S TREATED JUST
LIKE ANY OTHER INCOME. AND PAID
FOR IN THE SAME MANNER AS IT
WOULD BE IF IT WERE. IN THE
PAYCHECK DIRECTLY- FOR THAT
REASON WE- ORIGIN I VOTE- THIS
WAS ALSO NOT A SUBJECT TO
LITIGATION. IN ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA MARIN TO CONSOLIDATE
CASES SO THEREFORE IT SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE WE NEED. TO
CLARIFY THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
THE MICHAEL POWERS. THE BILL
IT'S ON THE TELECOM ONE IS THAT
CORRECT. YES THERE ARE YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON MY POWERS
OF THE TRUCK COUNTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- AND AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
A MEASURE THAT SEEKS TO CLARIFY
THE DEFINITION OF COMPENSATION
OR NOBLE AND RETIREMENT LAW TO
ENSURE THAT PENSION
CALCULATIONS CONTINUE TO
INCORPORATE THE COUNTY'S.
FLEXIBLE BENEFIT ALLOWANCE.
COULD PETITION IS CRITICALLY
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE
COUNTING PLEASE ARE NOT UNDULY
HARMED. TWENTY SIX A
DESTINATION IS RISEN FROM THE
SUPREME COURT ALAMEDA DECISION
IN WHICH THE COURT RULED THAT
PAPRIKA MODIFIED THE DEFINITION
OF COMPETITION UNABLE TO
EXCLUDE CERTAIN PAY ITEMS THAT
CONSTITUTED PENSION SPIKING.
YOU KNOW PENSION SPIKING IS
COMMONLY UNDERSTOOD TO INCLUDE
COMPENSATION COMPONENTS THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO
MANIPULATE TO INCREASE THEIR
PENSION CALCUATIONS. VENTURA
CASE HOWEVER THE COUNTY HAS
ALWAYS INCLUDED THE FLEX
BENEFIT BECAUSE IT IS A REGULAR
SET AMOUNT PAID EVERY PAY
PERIOD AND IS NOT SUBJECT. TO
PENSIONS BIKING OR ANY OTHER
MANIPULATION. AB EIGHT TWENTY
SIX HAS BEEN CAREFULLY CRAFTED
TO CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF
COMPETITION PRINTABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WHILE
PRESERVING AFTER A PENSION
REFORM. IMPORTANTLY AB TWO
EIGHT TWENTY SIX DOES NOT
IMPACT ANY BENEFITS
SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDED BY PEPPER.
DON'T EVEN TRY HAS FULLY
EMBRACED PENSION REFORM. THANKS
TO OUR LABOR PARTNERS I GUESS
YEAH YOU WE WERE IN FACT ONE OF
THE FIRST AND YOU COUNTIES TO
ACHIEVE FIFTY FIFTY NORMAL CAR
SHARING WITH OUR LEGACY
MEMBERS. OF PEPPER DID NOT
REQUIRE IT WE ALSO HAVE ONE OF
THE HIGHEST FUNDED PENSION
PLANS IN THE STATE AT NEARLY
90% FUNDED INCLUDING BOTH
GENERAL AND SAFETY EMPLOYEES.
FOR THIS BILL WILL NOT HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL IMPACT ON
US BECAUSE THE COST OF
INCLUDING THE FLEX BENEFIT IS
ALREADY INCLUDED IN OUR BUDGET
PROJECTIONS. THIS BILL WILL
ACTUALLY RESULT IN SAVINGS FOR
COUNTIES AND EXCLUDING THE
BENEFIT WILL NO DOUBT RESULT IN
COMPLEX AND COSTLY LABOR
NEGOTIATIONS DUE TO THE IMPACT
ON EMPLOYEES TOTAL
COMPLICATION. THE COUNTY ARE
LIKE IT'S EMPLOYERS HAVE PAID
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE RETIREMENT
SYSTEM FOR THIS BENEFIT FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS. EXCLUSION OF
THE BUT THE FLEX BENEFIT WOULD
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
OUR EMPLOYEES AND YOU PRODUCE
BUT THEIR LOWEST PAID WILL
CONTINUE REDUCTION IN THEIR
MONTHLY RETIREMENT INCOME AS
MUCH AS TEN PERCENT. CANCER THE
CREATED BY ALAMEDA HAS RESULTED
IN SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES FOR
COUNTY EMPLOYEES OUR LABOR
PARTNERS AND OUR RETIREMENT
SYSTEM. AB TWENTY SIX PROVIDES
MUCH NEEDED CLARITY FOR INTER
COUNTY AND OUR EMPLOYEES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. ARE YOU DOING THANK
YOU THAT. THE DELETE. OR ANYONE
HERE IN A COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES
TO TAKE A SUPPORT POSITION ON
A. B. A. TWENTY SIX. SO PLEASE
STEP TOWARD. ASEAN NO ONE WILL
LOOK AT THE OR FOR ROOM THERE'S
NO ONE THERE TO TESTIFY FOR
GOOD OR MODERATOR. S. A
MODERATOR TO PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANY SUPPORT TESTIMONY OF AB
EIGHT TWENTY SIX. AGAIN THIS IS
LIMITED TO NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION- AND WOULD APPRECIATE.
KNOWING THE NUMBER IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT TWENTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU- WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION NOW AND- WE
JUST WANT TO SAY WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS BUT
WILL ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE. IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WANTS TO TAKE IT OUT OPPOSE
POSITION ON THIS BILL. FOR ITS
C. NINE WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW
ROOM. SEEN NONE WILL COME BACK
TO MODERNISE MODERATOR- TO A
CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO TAKE OPPOSE
POSITION AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX ON
THE TELECONFERENCE ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION A.
B. EIGHT TWENTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU WELCOME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- FOR ANY COMMITTEE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. CONCERNS
SEEN NONE I WILL COME BACK
THIRTY AUTHOR FOR ALL I'M SORRY
CENTER NEUTRAL PLEASE PROCEED.
EL MOVING THE BILL. SO WE DO
HAVE- WE DO HAVE AN OFFER TO
MOVE THE BILL WITH YOU I TAKE
AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE FIRST AND
THEN WE'LL GET RIGHT TO THE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN I WILL AGAIN WANT TO
THANK YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFFORD THEIR ASSISTANCE ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE I WILL BE
AS I MENTIONED ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AS
DESCRIBED ON PAGE FIVE THAT
CLARIFY POST JULY THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY COMPENSATION ALSO
REQUIRES BOTH THE EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEES TO FULLY FUND PENSION
CONTRIBUTIONS AND AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE I COMMIT TO
THE WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO CLARIFY THE
REMAINING TECHNICAL ISSUES AND
WITH THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER NEWMAN IN LAS
CONSULTANT TO TAKE A ROLL CALL
NOW. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED COURTESY. BY BUT DOES
THE FIVE OR CHOI BOGUE NO BUT
SHOW UP OPEN NO THE DESKTOP.
THE REST I LAYERED. LEHRER I
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEW HI BIRDS
BILL'S OF AN ONE THANK YOU.
YOUR THERE'S NO OBJECTION THE
COMMITTEE GOING. TO ONE BILL
OUT OF ORDER IN THE THAT WOULD
BE WELL I SEVEN A. B. ONE ZERO
ZERO THREE- THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ IS HERE AND
THERE'S BEEN AN ARRANGEMENT TO
HAVE HER. UNCLE NEXT IN THEM WE
WILL FILL FACTOR FOR ORDER AT
THAT POINT. SOME REPUBLICANS
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND-
THANK TO MY SIMPLY COLLEAGUES
WHO SO GRACIOUSLY ALLOWED ME TO
GO BEFORE HER AND BATTLING
MULTIPLE. HEARINGS AS SOME OF
YOUR AS WELL. ABM TENNIS IS
REALLY SIMPLE IT JUST SAYS HEY
IF THERE'S INTENTIONAL WAGE
THEFT BY AN EMPLOYER THAT THEY
ARE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
PENALTIES CRIMINAL PENALTIES AS
AN EMPLOYEE WOULD BE IF THEY
WERE STEALING FROM THEIR
EMPLOYER. IN OTHER WORDS IT'S
NO LONGER JUST A SLAP ON THE
WRIST IF- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY AS
AN EMPLOYEE IF YOU WENT AND YOU
SOLD A THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
YOUR EMPLOYER YOU WOULD END UP
IN JAIL. HOWEVER FOR DECADES
NOW EMPLOYERS HAVE
INTENTIONALLY STOLEN FROM
WORKERS AND THE BEST THAT THEY
GET IS A SLAP ON THE WRIST AND
MAYBE A FINE FROM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND THEN IF THEY
ACTUALLY UNDO THEIR COMPANY
CAN'T FIND THEM IN MOST OF
THOSE GO UNPAID. SO WE WANT THE
OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY WITH A
NEW FOUND PROGRESSIVE.
PROSECUTORS IN THE STATE TO
ACTUALLY GO AFTER WAGE THAT IN
A. M. AS A CRIMINAL PENALTY IT
HAS TO BE INTENTIONAL THIS
ISN'T LIKE SOME. SMALL LITTLE
VIOLATIONS THIS IS
INTENTIONALLY KEEPING WAGES. OR
TIPS AWAY FROM- EMPLOYEES WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE SOME WITNESSES. THANK YOU.
THE LEAD SUPPORT. OF PROVISION
IS ON THE TELECONFERENCE ON IS
LIKE. CORRECT YOU MAY PROCEED.
MY NAME AFTER TOP WRITER CAN
AND I'VE BEEN A LICENSE
ESTHETICIAN TENTH OCTOBER.
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. I'M AT THIRTY
YEARS OLD I WANTED FULL TIME
WORK AFTER SPENDING FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET LIKE
THAT IN FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN I WAS HIRED AT A BEAUTY
SALON AND VIDEO THIRTY OTHER W.
TWO EMPLOYEE THE MANAGER TOLD
ME THAT I WOULD BE MAKING
THIRTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR I OKAY
HE WOULD PROVIDE GRANTS
TRAINING ON PRODUCTS AND HE
WOULD WORK WITH MY SCHEDULE AND
AVAILABILITY. THAT I WOULD
EVENTUALLY BE FULL TIME BEFORE
THAT. THE TRAIN. THE MANAGER
DIRECTLY TO COME IN FOR AND-
URGENT QUITE WORK CLASS FOR
LAST YEAR THANK YOU. I PROVIDED
MY OWN PRODUCT SERVICE TO
APPROXIMATELY THREE OUT
INCLUDING. ANY CLEANING. THE
MANAGER A CRIME CARD ON MY
BEHALF. BUT ONLY FOR THE HOURS
TRYING I ACTUALLY WITH THE
CLIENT I WOULD NOT FOR MY-
SPENT. SETTING UP OR CLEANING
AND I WOULD NOT REMAIN FOR MY
PRODUCT. YEAH BECAME THE
STANDARD FOR THE IN THING
MONTHS WAS EMPLOYED AT THE A
LOT. I COULD NOT HAVE. HANDLED
HOURS. I THINK BE ON. NINETY
THREE. WITHOUT WHEN I WANT. THE
OWNER WOULD CLOCK ME OUT WHEN I
WHEN IN WITH A CAR. I ONLY PAID
CRIME BANK THE CLIENT. I NEVER.
TRAINING I NEVER NEVER WE- FOR
PRODUCT I FREQUENTLY HAD A
FIVE. I WOULD NOT BE ONLY IN.
EXPERIENCE WAIT STAFF AT. THE.
ONE I DO NOT CONTINUE. IN QUITE
UNINFORMED AND BONOBO EMPLOYEE.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I WILL MOVE TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE HER IN THE ROOM
WHO WISHES TO TAKE A SUPPORT
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE
COMPORT IDENTIFY YOURSELF THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GAIL STEWARD
ON BEHALF OF SUMMER STEPHAN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF AB
TEN OH THREE THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM- WISHING TO TAKE
A SUPPORT POSITION ON THIS
BILL. IF SO PLEASE COME FORWARD
ASSENAGON- WE WILL CHECK YOUR
FULL ROOM FOR. WITNESSES WE SEE
NONE. WILL MOVE TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED MODERATOR. BUT
THE PICTURETEL CONFERENCE LINE
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS A SUPPORT POSITION ON
AB. ONE ZERO ZERO THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB. AND THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR FIRST COMMENT. WE DO HAVE
TWO PARTIES IN Q. THANK YOU.
ONE TO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS RACHEL
NATURALLY ON TOP OF THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION AND FROM
SUPPORT. NINE TO EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS WENDY
KAUFMAN FROM CALIFORNIA SENATE
ALLIANCE ON BEHALF OF SEVEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN OUR GROUP
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. TEN.
THREE THANK YOU. ONE TO THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JAMIE SHOT BACK ON BEHALF OF
PRECISION NAILS AND WEARING
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB CHANNEL
THREE. AND WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT WE'RE JUST WAITING ON
THE LINE NUMBER ONE MOM. ONE TO
THIRTY SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD JIM
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS WHAT. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT INTO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR OF
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK TO THE
OPPOSITION SIDE THERE'S NO WITH
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
CHECK THE COMMITTEE ROOM AT
THIS TIME SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS IN OPPOSE
POSITION. ON THIS BILL. AB TEN
OH THREE I GUESS IS A BETTER
WAY TO SAY IT SEEN NONE WILL
LOOK TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM SCENE
THE WITNESSES THERE WILL COME
BACK TO THE MODERATOR. NASA
MODERATOR- TO CHECK FOR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY ON AB. TEN
OH THREE. THANK YOU MR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
OH THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN OH THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
THERE. WE HAVE NO WINNING QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU YOUR
MODERATOR I WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND- CHECK FOR
HER COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
CENTER NEWMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SERVED A CABINET ASSEMBLY WON'T
SHOW AT LAST WEEK I HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESIONS AND A
COUPLE OF YOUR BILLS- THIS
WEEKEND LETTER FOR I HAVE NO
SUCH QUESTIONS. THIS IS A GOOD
BILL I AM MORE THAN PERSUADED
THAT WAGE THEFT IS RAMPANT
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BETWEEN THE
SERVICE ECONOMY- AND THE
PROVISION PROVISION YOUR BILL
MAKE GOOD SENSE TO ME AS THEY
SAY GOOD FENCES MAKE GOOD
NEIGHBORS THERE'S NO REASON.
WHY WE SHOULD INCREASE
DETERRENCE AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL
GET BETTER ENFORCEMENT AND
HEARING SHOULD THE CLASS WITH
THE BILL. LARA ANYWAY ALSO WISH
TO COMMENT ON THE BILL CENTER
DRAWS OF. I DON'T KNOW IF THERE
WAS A MOVE FOR EXONERATION WAS.
IS NOW. OKAY WELL- I REYES AND-
IN SUPPORT AND IT WAS
INTERESTING THE WAY YOU SAID
THAT IF I COULD TO THE AUTHOR
THAT WHEN IT'S- WHEN IT'S AN
EMPLOYER DEPRIVE BEING. AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE WAGES OWED IT'S
A LABOR VIOLATIONS- WHICH IS
THE SMALLEST KIND OF PENALTY
THAT YOU COULD EVER GET BUT IF
IT'S AN EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE AND
EMPLOYER IS TAKING FROM THE
EMPLOYEE THEN IT'S- FOR ME IT'S
WITH THE WAY WE'RE AROUND IT
SHOULD BE- GRAND THEFT SO
ANYWAY I THINK- THIS IS TO
CLARIFY THE WHEN YOU STEAL YOU
STEAL. IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU
THE EMPLOYER THE EMPLOYEE IF
YOU'RE STEALING FROM ONE
ANOTHER. AND STEALING SOMEONE'S
ABILITY TO SURVIVE IN. BUT FOOD
ON THE TABLE IS PROBABLY THE
WORST KIND OF THEFT ANYBODY
COULD ENGAGE IN SOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER CIRCLE- CENTER
WEIRD WERE YOU LIVING IN THE
HOUSE OF. ALL RIGHT- WE DO HAVE
A PROMOTION AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- FIT LIKE CLOSE YOU MAY.
THANKS AND I JUST WANA POINT
OUT- CENTER NEWMAN'S HIT ON THE
HEAD ITS DETERRENCE WE KNOW
THAT- FROM SPECIALLY THOSE OF
US WHO WENT TO LAW SCHOOL YOU
YOU HEAR ABOUT COMPANIES MAKING
THESE REALLY TERRIBLE. BUT COST
BENEFIT DECISIONS ON WHETHER OR
NOT TO DO CERTAIN THINGS BASED
ON THE COST OF DOING AND OFTEN
WHEN IT COMES TO LABOR LAW
VIOLATIONS IT'S ACTUALLY
CHEAPER- TO VIOLATE THE LAW AND
TO SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES
THROUGH THEN R. B. OR THROUGH
THE LABOR OMMISSIONER THAN IT
IS TO ACTUALLY PAY. ENTRY
WORKERS CORRECTLY WE NEED TO
RETHINK THAT AND I HOPE THERE
ARE A LOT OF- CORPORATE
TOURNEY'S OUT THERE WHO ARE
STARTING THEIR MEMOS ON WHAT
WHAT CAN HAPPEN TO YOU IF YOU.
CHOOSE TO- SKIRT THE LAW AND IT
ISN'T JUST A SIMPLE A FINE WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SOUNDS
LIE. THE FORD PINTO CASE WHEN
YOU PUT IT THAT WAY. REMEMBER
THAT THEY DO. THE SO WE DO A
PROMOTION THE OFFICE CLOSING
LOSS THE CONSULTANT TO TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY. BUT AS
THE I OR CHOI BOGUE. A TROUBLE
GUY TO WRESTLE HI THE REST SO I
LAYERED HI THERE I NEWMAN HI
NEWMAN AYE. THE RAID ON THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE FOR THE BILL
WITHOUT THANK YOU. FORWARD INTO
A BACK TO OUR- ORIGINAL THE
REMAINING PHùORDER IS AB
SEVEN NINETY FOUR- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO BILL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CREWS HERE AND YOUR
PERSONAL WELCOME AND- YOU'RE
ALSO WELCOME 2% WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS AB SEVEN NINE FOUR
IS A STEP IN LINKING SUBSIDIES
FOR CLEAN VEHICLES TO LABOR AND
JOB QUALITY STANDARDS STATE
MONEY SPENT FOR CLEAN VEHICLES
CAN DO MORE THAN REDUCE
EMISSIONS IT CAN ALSO REDUCE
THE ITS MISSION. OF WORKERS AND
THE INDUSTRY IS TARGETED FOR
SUBSIDIES AB SEVEN NINE FOUR
WILL ENSURE THAT PUBLIC FUNDS
ADMINISTERED BY CARD FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ZERO EMISSIONS-
PORTRAYED IN SHORT HAUL TRUCKS
ARE TIED TO LABOR STANDARDS
SPECIFICALLY THAT TO THE
REQUIREMENT THAT FLEET
PURCHASERS NOT VIOLATE STATE
LAWS. REGARDING THE MISS
CLASSIFICATION OF WORKERS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THE
ABILITY OF THE STATE TO MAKE TO
MEET AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS
DEPENDS ON THE LARGE LARGELY
IN- LARGE PART ON FLEET
PURCHASERS TRANSITIONING TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. PARKED
TRUCK DRIVERS ARE A CRITICAL
PART OF THAT SUPPLY CHAIN
MOVING GOODS FROM THE SHIPS TO
END UP IN WAREHOUSES AND BIG
BOX STORES ACROSS THE STATE
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS ALSO PLAY A
MAJOR SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND PRODUCE. TOXIC
AIR POLLUTION THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
SURROUNDING THE PORT THE MORE
THOSE PORTS ACTUALLY AND WHERE
THOSE TRUCKS TRAVEL TO- IN MY
DISTRICT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE. POINT CHINA IS
OVERLAID WITH SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY FOUR WE HAVE THE TWO
FREEWAY THE ONE THIRTY FOUR THE
FIVE THE SIXTY THE TEN THE ONE
TEN THE TEN FREEWAY. MORE THAN
SEVEN FREEWAYS THAT US AROUND
OUR COMMUNITIES AND SO THE
ISSUE OF CLEAN AIR IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITY AND
TO THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT.
I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT A MAJOR
OBSTACLE OF MEETING CLIMATE
GOALS ESTIMATES CLASSIFICATION
APPORTER APART TRUCK DRIVERS A
NUMBER OF STUDIES SHOW THAT
BETWEEN 75285% OF PORT WORKERS
ARE MISCLASSIFIED. MEANING THEY
ARE DEEMED DENIED MINIMUM WAGE
OVERTIME PAID SICK LEAVE AND
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR FUEL AND
VEHICLE MAINTENANCE.
MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS CANNOT
AFFORD NEW CLEAN OR ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS. WHEN THE
BURDEN OF THAT COST IS
PURCHASED AND MAINTAIN AND
MAINTAIN VEHICLES FALLS ON
THEM. AND NOT ON THE TRUCKING
COMPANIES. LABOR STANDARDS ON
PUBLIC SUBSIDIES CAN BEGIN TO
SHIFT THE BUSINESS MODEL IN
TRUCKING. FROM EXTREME WORKER
EXPLOITATION. AND HEAVY
EMISSIONS AND AIR POLLUTION. TO
BETTER JOB QUALITY FOR DRIVERS
AND CLEANER AIR FOR
COMMUNITIES. AB SEVEN NINE FOUR
CREATES AN INCENTIVE FOR
EMPLOYERS TO COMPLY WITH
EXISTING LAW. AND WILL PREVENT
PUBLIC MONEY FROM SUPPORTING.
MISS CLASSIFICATION LOW WAGE
JOBS AND ILLEGAL LABOR
PRACTICES. AT THIS CRITICAL
MOMENT OF TRANSITION TO A CLEAN
ECONOMY CALIFORNIA CANNOT
AFFORD TO FAIL ON COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGIES TO ENSURE THAT
CLIMATE JOBS ARE GOOD JOBS. TO
GROW OUR ECONOMY AND BENEFIT
WORKERS AND THE ENVIRONMENT WE
CAN DO BOTH. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS MATTER
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SEVEN NINE FOR SEVERAL BLOCKS
REPRESENTING THE TEAMSTERS PORT
DIVISION. AND SOME APPEL WITH
THE CAL A CALIFORNIA POLICY
MANAGER WITH THE BLUE GREEN
ALLIANCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT THE IN THE
WILL TURN TO LEAD SUPPORT WHEN
THE SERVER FOX'S HERE IN PERSON
AND THEN MAY PROCEED. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THERE ARE FLOCKS
REPRESENTING THE TEAMSTERS PORT
DIVISION AT CO SPONSOR AND
PROUD TO BE PART OF A COALITION
OF LABOR COMMUNITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS THAT ARE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL- LOW
INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. BEAR THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF GHG
EMISSIONS AIR POLLUTION AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND KNOW WHERE
IS THAT MORE CLEAR THAN AT THE
PORTS AND IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR. AT THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
SAID YOU HAVE THESE HEAVY DUTY
DRAYAGE AND SHORT HAUL TRUCKS
THAT ARE MOVING GOODS ALL OVER
THE PORT THERE HEAVY HIGH
EMITTER SO HEAVY DUTY HIGH
EMITTERS THEY'RE GETTING ON
THESE FREEWAYS AND THEN THEY'RE
GOING OUT TO DISTRIBUTION
WAREHOUSES IN THE INLAND.
BETTER THAN SENDING GOODS
THROUGH AMAZON GOING TO BIG BOX
STORES. AND THE COMMUNITIES
ALONG THIS ROUTE ARE THE ONES
WHO SUFFER WHO ARE THE ONES WHO
HAVE HIGHER ASTHMA RATES HIGHER
RISK OF CANCER AND- MORE AIR
POLLUTION IN THE AIR AND THEN
IN THE PORTS. MISCLASSIFIED
PORT TRUCK DRIVERS ALSO SUFFER.
EIGHT THERE'S BEEN MULTIPLE
STUDIES THAT HAVE SHOWN THAT
MISCLASSIFIED TRUCK DRIVERS
ONES WHO ARE NOT GETTING
MINIMUM WAGE OVERTIME IN THE
RIGHTS OF BEING AN EMPLOYEE I
EAT. EARN LESS THAN DIRECTLY
EMPLOYED TRUCK DRIVERS. AND YET
THEY HAVE HIGHER CAPITAL COSTS
AND ARE EXPECTED TO BUY THEIR
OWN ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS THEY
SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD. SO THAT IS
AN OBSTACLE TO MEETING OUR
STATE CLIMATE GOALS. AB SEVEN
SEVEN NINETY FOUR IS A STEP
FORWARD IN THAT IT SAYS. BEFORE
YOU'RE ABLE TO GET A SUBSIDY
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH TAXPAYER DOLLARS YOU HAVE
TO SHOW THAT YOU ARE NOT MISS
CLASS THAT YOU'RE NOT HAVE
VIOLATIONS OF LAW RELATED TO
MISS CLASSIFICATION. IT'S A
VERY SIMPLE BILL AND IT REALLY
IS TRYING TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYERS
AND CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR
TRUCKING COMPANIES TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH LABOR LAW. AND
WITH CLINICAL SO WE ARE DRIVE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY PRO IF YOU WERE
ON THE TELECONFERENCE ON YOU WE
PROCEED KNACKS. HI THERE GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
GREEN ALLIANCE IS AN ALLIANCE
OF TEN LABOR UNIONS AND
PRIVATE. ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
TEAMSTERS UNITED AUTO WORKERS
ENERGY THE- AND ARE AMONG OUR
MEMBERS DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THIS
BILL. EARLIER VERSIONS OF
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR. ALSO
INCENTIVIZE CALIFORNIAN
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND THIS IS ONE OF THE-
DO THE AUTO INDUSTRY OPPOSITE.
ALL THE MANUFACTURING
PROVISIONS REMOVED FROM THIS
BILL. UNTIL RECENTLY REAP WE
RETAINED INTENT LANGUAGE THAT
THE CORE U. S. IN CALIFORNIA
VEHICLE MANUFACTURING AND
HIRING JOBS FOR DISADVANTAGED
WORKERS. HOWEVER WITH CONTINUED
AUTO INDUSTRY OPPOSITION WE
DECIDED TO REMOVE THE AT BAT
AND CAN LANGUAGE IT
STRENGTHENING IMPORTANT
TRUCKING. GOAL WE CAN GET IN A
CONTINUING THE AUTO AND
CRAFTING THE NOTHING
MANUFACTURING. I'M THE RATE THE
BILL COLLECTOR VEHICLES
MANUFACTURES ARE CURRENTLY OFF
SHORING PRODUCTION LINES INTO
JOBS IN THE U. S. HELLO WAIT
REGIONS OF THE WORLD. THIS
DEVELOPMENT COULD NOT COME AT
THE WORST TIME MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS IN CONVENTIONAL AUTO
PRODUCTION AND OIL AND GAS DRY
UP. HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF.
US JOBS ARE ON THE LINE AN EASY
TRANSITION. ORGANIZED LABOR
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND YOU'D BE
AT THE KIDS ARE DEEPLY ALIGNED
ON EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR.
AND ALSO ON AUTO MANUFACTURING
THE US PGA AND INDUSTRY EXPERTS
REALLY RECENTLY RELEASED A
STUDY SHOWING THAT DOMESTIC TV.
PRODUCTION DOES NOT DOES NOT
CONFLICT WITH CALIFORNIA
DEVIANT OPTION ENVIRONMENTAL
OBJECTIVES AND COULD CREATE
FIFTY THOUSAND US IN CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING JOBS. EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY FOUR AND A CURRENT
FORM REMAINS THE PIVOTAL AND
ESSENTIAL BILL REDUCING THE
CLASSIFICATION AND ADVANCING
OUR CLIMATE GOALS PGA
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE THE
COMMITTEE IN THE CRITICAL. WORK
AHEAD ON ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
SORRY THE COMPLETED. ON BOTH
SEE IF THE ANYONE HERE IN THE
CAN ROOM WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS.
A SUPPORT POSITION ON AB SEVEN
NINETY FOUR. C. NONE WILL CHECK
YOUR FULL ROOM OBSCENE NO
WITNESSES THERE READY TO
TESTIFY. WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE OPERATOR- THE
MODERATOR ASK YOU TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT POSITIONS
ON AB SEVEN NINETY FOUR.
CENTRIC YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
NINETY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SEVEN IN THE
QUEUE. FINE TWO THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHANG MEMBERS
CAITLIN DATA ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION
OF LABOR AND UNITE LOCAL ELEVEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE TWO
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
MEMBERSHIP JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL. WHO'S GOING TO
THE BILL BROWN'S APPOINTED
THANK YOU. NINE TO THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NIKITA KARATE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NO. ONE TO THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHOW THIS TO BE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT. NINE
TO THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
AUTO WORKERS REGION EIGHT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TO
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR EDUARDO MARTINEZ
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. NINE TO
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN NINETY
FOUR THANK YOU. NINE TO TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIND TWO TWENTY NINE
PM. GO AHEAD PLEASE. JESSICA
DURHAM WITH LANE L. A. LINES
INTO A CONDOMINIUM OR PROUD
COACH. IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
TO TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ERIN
RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER. COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE T THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL COME
BACK TO OPPOSITION- THERE'S NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS WHO HAS
BEEN LISTED UP WITH THE
COMMITTEE SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK
FOR IS ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO TAKE IN
OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS BILL.
SEE NON WILL CHECK YOUR FULL
ROOM. AND THERE'S NONE WILL
COME BACK THE MODERATOR ON THE
B. SEVEN NINETY FOUR MODERATOR
BUT THIS TIME. AND OPPOSITION.
I DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
N OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN
NINETY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN
NINETY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE
ONE COMMON IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU. MIND TO
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION- AND OPPOSING THE
LESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE BILL
WITH AMENDMENTS TAKEN SEVENTY
Q. WE LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING TO
NO POSITION. WAS AMENDMENTS
JUST CAME OUT THIS MORNING SO
WE'RE WE'RE REVIEWING NOW.
THANK YOU. OKAY I BELIEVE A
MODERATOR THIS THAT- CONCLUDES
THE OPPOSITION TESTIMONY UNTIL
COVERAGE ON. THE CORRECT
CORRECT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. SCENE
NO ONE WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED
WILL COME BACK TO THE AUTHOR
INTO UP TO THE COAST. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I SAY%
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU ON
CHAIRING THIS COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE IT IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT I PERCENT BEFORE YOU. A.
B. SEVEN NINE FOUR IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO ACTUALLY
MAKE THE CALIFORNIA GREEN NEW
DEAL A REALITY BOTH ONE THAT
ACTUALLY WORKS FOR WORKERS. AND
ONE THAT PROTECTS OUR
ENVIRONMENT WE CAN DO BOTH
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO REASON
WHY. WE CANNOT HAVE A REAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT A JUST
TRANSITION A WORKFORCE ACTUALLY
LOOKS LIKE TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE. BUILDING THE TYPE OF
CLEANING KANEMI AND- REALLY
JUST. GREEN ENVIRONMENTS THAT
ARE COMMUNITIES NEED THAT ARE
MOST AT NEED SO WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
QUICKLY SENATOR RUSSELL IS MOVE
THE BILL- WILL COULD NASA FOR
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY. OR
DOES HE DIE A CHOI BOGUE NO THE
TROUBLED NOW. WRESTLE THE
RUSSELL I LAYERED. LETTERED BY
NEWMAN NEWMAN HI WHEN THE FOR
THE WIND BLOWS THE BILL'S OUT
THANK YOU FOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA WE'RE GOING TO GET OUR
POLICE IN ORDER FOR YOU HERE
AND- IT'S WORKED OUT THE YEAR
TWO BILLS IN THE ADDRESS TO THE
FORWARD TO BACK TO BACK SO. WE
ARE. WE KNOW THERE'S NO
PRESSURE THAT YOU'RE STANDING
BEFORE US AND ADJOURNMENTS BUT
WILL- GIVE YOU EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO. A FULLY
PRESENT- LET ME JUST INDICATE
THAT THE FIRST BUILDINGS- BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA THAT WILL
BE PRESENTED FILE ITEM THREE IS
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE- AND AGAIN
YOU MAY PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH- INSURE CORTESE AND
MEMBERS. I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
AB FIFTY SIXTY ONE OF THE LABOR
COMMITTEE BILL WHICH IS A
FOLLOW UP TO LEGISLATION TO
EIGHTY TWO POINT FIFTY SEVEN A
TOTAL OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE EMPLOYMENT STATUS OF THE
APPLICATION ABC TEST- THIS BILL
MAKES THE FOLLOWING CHANGES AND
CLARIFICATIONS EXTENDS FOR
THREE YEARS. UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE
SUNSET. ON THE EXEMPTION FROM
THE APPLICATION THE ABC TEST
FOR LICENSE MANAGERS WITH A
HIGH DEGREE OF CONTROL OVER
THEIR WORK. EXTENDS ALSO FOR
THREE YEARS EXEMPTION FROM THE
ABC TEST FOR SUBCONTRACTORS. IN
THE CONSTRUCTION TRUCKING
INDUSTRY. PROBLEM OCCURS
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE IS NOT
REQUIRED AND WHO SATISFIED.
SPECIFIED REQUIREMENTS. BUT AS
FOR THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
EXEMPTION TO THE ABC TEST
PERSONS PERFORM CLAIMS
ADJUSTING OR THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATION. AND IT
CLARIFIES A DATA AGGREGATOR
EXAM TOMORROW FROM TO AN
INDIVIDUAL. WHO PROVIDES
FEEDBACK AS A RESEARCH SUBJECT
AND REMOVES LANGUAGE SPECIFYING
THE COMPENSATION THEY RECEIVED.
AS EQUIVALENT TO AN HOURLY WAGE
RATE IS- YOU ALL KNOW. WITH AB
FIVE IN SUBSEQUENT EIGHTY FIVE
THERE'S BEEN THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF WORK IN TERMS OF. THE REAL
WORLD IMPACTS TO TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO APPROPRIATE
AMENDMENTS- AND HAVE
APPROPRIATE SUNSET LANGUAGE
THAT STILL PROTECTS THE WRITER
WORKERS WHILE RECOGNIZING. THE
WIDE RANGE OF DIVERSE TYPES OF
WORK THAT EXISTS IN OUR STATE I
WANT TO COMMEND- AS A MEMBER OF
THE MENA GONZALEZ FOR. HER
EFFORTS AND KIND OF PICKING UP.
THE BATON SO TO SPEAK IN
ENSURING THAT SOME OF THESE
CLEAN FOR THE CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION REFLECTS. WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR WORK- VARIETY
OF WORK ENVIRONMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND THE BILL- HAS
BEEN ON CONSENT THROUGHOUT THE
ASSEMBLY AND HERE I HOPE. I
URGE AND I BOOKED AND-
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN- WILL
NOTE THAT. THERE'S NO LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS IDENTIFIED BUT
WE WILL ASK IF THERE'S AYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
POSITION ONLY BE. FIFTEEN SIXTY
ONE. AND A. PLEASE COULDN'T
COME THE MICROPHONE THANK YOU.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN RICH CHRIS
MCCAIN ON B. OF TWO CLIENTS- ON
SET. FOUR RELAY TO THE PIECE
ASSOCIATION OF. PER AND SECTION
THREE OF THE BILL THE INSIGHTS
ASSOCIATION AND- AS THE CHAIR
OF THE POLICY COMMITTEE IN THE
ASSEMBLY NOTED WE WORKED WITH
HIM AND HIS STAFF. MISS
GONZALEZ AND YOUR STAFF AND
OTHERS IN. ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS-
EFFORTS IN THIS AREA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU
ANYONE WISHING TO- IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES AS SUPPORT ALONG
WITH THEIR AFFILIATION YOU MAY
PLEASE COME FORWARD. IF YOU'RE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM- THE
SAME IS TRUE IF YOU'RE IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM. OF SEEN THE
WITNESSES- OF THE SAME IS TRUE
OF YOUR ON THE TELECONFERENCE
ON ANGELES MODERATED PLEASE
IDENTIFY ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TAKE A SUPPORT POSITION ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE AT THIS
TIME. AND WE ALWAYS APPRECIATE
YOU LETTING US KNOW THE NUMBER
IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CITIZENS
OTTOMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SIXTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT-THIS TIME. NINE TO EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TO EIGHTEEN YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS WENDY KAUFMAN
FROM CALIFORNIA STATIC LINE AND
ON BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS AND
OUR MANAGERS WE SUPPORT.
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE. AND MINE TO
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JAMIE SHOT BACK LICENSE
MANICURIST AND EMPLOYEE BASE
SALON OWNER ON BEHALF OF
PRECISION NAIL BRAND STRONG
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WILL COME BACK TO
OPPOSITION I CAN- WILL NOTE
THAT THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
IDENTIFIED THAT SAID LAST COULD
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WISHES TO STEP FORWARD AND
TAKE IN OPPOSE POSITION ON AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE. SCENE NO
ONE- WE WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW
ROOM FOR WITNESSES THERE ARE
NONE. WELCOME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR MOTOR TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY Q. UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ONLY BE
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU MR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
GENERAL. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY COMMENTS
CONCERNS- QUESTIONS. ON THE
BOAT. THE BOOK BILLS REMOVED BY
SENATOR LAYERED- YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WILL SOME OF THEM THANK
YOU EXPRESSED ACROSS FROM ABOUT
THIRTY THANK YOU AND- LESS
CONSULTANT PLEASE TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY BY OR TO THE I OR
TROUBLED HI. BUT SHOVEL GUY
DRESS UP. THE WRESTLE I LAYERED
HI THERE I NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN
AYE. ON A VOTE OF FIVE ZERO-
THE BILL IS OUT. AND SO- WE
MOVE ON TO. IDM NINE AGAIN-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA IS THE
AUTHOR IN THIS IS AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU'RE
PREPARED TO MAKE GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR MATURE MEMBERS ON
HERE. AB FIFTY SIX WHICH
RELATES TO THE CURRENT
TEMPORARY EXEMPTION OF THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY FROM ABC
TEST FOR EMPLOYMENT STATUS THIS
BILL IS THE RESULT OF
THOUGHTFUL GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS THE INDUSTRY
SPECIFICALLY IN THE NEW THE NEW
NEWS OUR PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION
S WELL AS CONSULTATION
FEEDBACK FROM LABOR
STAKEHOLDERS. AB FIFTY OH SIX
WILL EXTEND THE TEMPORARY
EXEMPTION FROM THE ABC TEST FOR
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS. FOR THREE
YEARS SAID EXPIRES ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THIS
EXTENSION INCLUDES CRITICAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER
FOR THE STATE TO ASSESS THE USE
OF THE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
MODEL IN THE INDUSTRY.
UNDERSTAND ANY TRENDS IN
CARRICK KERRIER MISS
CLASSIFICATION. AND ENSURE THE
PUBLISHERS AND DISTRIBUTORS ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE PAROLE TEST
PROPONENT STATUS. THE AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S A SURPRISE OR
THE- THAT ALL THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS A RESOURCE NOT- NEWS
ANYONE OF THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
THERE'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT MORE
HOSTILITY I THINK IN SOME OF
THE EFFORTS ARE BROUGHT FORWARD
OF PARTICULARLY IN TERMS OF THE
ASSEMBLY LABOUR COMMITTEE AND-
KIND OF A LACK OF COMMUNICATION
I THINK THIS YEAR. IS SHOWN A
LOT MORE PROMISE IN TERMS OF
GOOD FAITH CONVERSATIONS
NEGOTIATIONS AND EFFORTS ARE
NOT ONLY FROM THE NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION BUT-
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON LABOR TO
AT LEAST TRY TO FIND OF SOME
POWERFUL WORD THAT PROVIDES FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR DATA- THE
WHEN YOU HAVE DIFFERENT-
VARYING ARGUMENTS AS TO WHAT
PATH FORWARD SHOULD BE TAKEN I
THINK WE NEED TO GET
INFORMATION TO RELIEVE OF
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE DO LONG
TERM. AS IT APPLIES TO THIS
INDUSTRY AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT ROLE
THAT NEWSPAPERS PLAY IN
EDUCATING AND INFORMING OUR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT CRITICAL
ISSUES IMPACTING THEM BUT DOES
SO WITH THE LEVEL OVERSIGHT
NECESSARY TO ENSURE NEWSPAPERS
COMPLIANCE A STATE LABOR LAW
AND WITH OTHERS BUT WE AS WE
ARE THOSE. OKAY THANK YOU SOME
ROOM UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS BRITNEY BAR
SAUDI IN A PRETTY PRECISE. OF
TELECONFERENCE LINE YOU MAY
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON LECTURE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE I
WANT TO START BY THINKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA IN THE
BACK FOR ALL OF THE WORK THEY
HAVE DEDICATED ON THAT ISSUE. I
AM GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE REPRESENT
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
PUBLICATIONS AND CALIFORNIA AND
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF AB
FIFTY SIX. FISH AND POLITICAL
LIKE TO THINK THE MEMBERS
HOLDING HAS SUPPORTED LOCAL
JOURNALIST THAT I AM PREPARED
DEDICATED WORK ON LABOR ISSUES.
ARE YOU KNOW SB FIFTY SX WORKS
THEN THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS- CARRIER STATUS FOR
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS. TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WHILE ALSO
REQUIRING. THE CHOIR HE DATA
THAT AGE AND HELPFUL TO ME AND
CREATURE- THIS YEAR WE STARTED
MARK MR CALL TO BUY A COMMON
SENSE SOLUTION FOR INDIA'S NEED
FOR ANY PILOT. PART OF. THEY
CALL THEIRS AND LABOR CAN. AND
OTHER RELIGIOUS TO CONCERNS
WITH THE CALL BY YOUR LONG
SCHOOL PRINTED CARE. DURING
DEPRESSION PROVIDE INCOMING
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC STATE OF OUR
INDUSTRY AS BOTH. YOU SHOULD
MODEL PROBLEM. SOLVED OVER TIME
AND- TRAGICALLY DUE TO DIGITAL.
ADMIN FOR ROUGHLY NINETY PER
CAL PUBLICATION ONLY WE CREATED
HOW ARE BUT PUBLIC A MIX THREE.
A WEEK WHY THEY THEIR WHAT
CONTENT THOSE MEDIA ON A DAILY.
EVERYONE WE SPOKE WITH
RECOGNIZED OUR MEMBERS ARE
PROBABLY BEING THE RESOURCES
RECORDING ESSENTIAL NEWS WHILE
PROVIDING INFORMATION THAT
INFORMS AND EDUCATES ENTERTAINS
LEADERS AND THE FIRST
COMMUNITIES. ACROSS OUR STATE.
GREAT FOR THE RECOGNIZE. I
REMEMBER PUBLIC MORE THAN HARD
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
BECAUSE THEY- HE'S BACK ON THE
LOCATION- CALDERON STRETCH AND
GLOBAL REOPENING. I AM AND-
COUNTY GOT. WELL AS I THANKS
SUPPORT AT YOUR AS WELL. DURING
THE PANDEMIC OUR ONE
PUBLICATION PREVENT CREDIT HARD
BY STATE AVERAGE MARKET IS
DIFFERENT ACROSS THE STREET.
BUT COULD BE MAKING A WILDFIRE
COVERAGE IN FRONT OF BETTER A
WALL TO KEEP CALIFORNIANS SAFE.
WITH AB FIFTY SIXTY BENJAMIN
PROPOSED BECAUSE EVERY SURVEY
OF CALIFORNIA PUBLICATIONS
SHOWS THAT NEARLY FORTY
PERCENT. OF PUBLICATIONS WOULD
HAVE TO CONSIDER CLOSING THEIR
DOORS. FIFTY FOUR BECAUSE THAT
WOULD CONSIDER ELIMINATE
DELIVERY AREAS AND FIFTY SEVEN
BECAUSE THAT WOULD RAISE
PRICES. AND AN ADDITIONAL. US
71% OF. CONSIDERING STAFF- ONLY
BE A EIGHT INCREASED COSTS. ARE
COMMONLY WILL PROBABLY CONTINUE
PUBLIC. BOB ALL WORK TOGETHER
BY KEEPING OUR- AND- ABOUT THIS
VIDEO BILLION AND THE LATEST
PUBLICLY THE INFORMATION WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE OUR WORK
WITH MISTER KALRA AND THE STATE
HOLDERS. ON THE MECHANICS OF
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO
ENSURE AN ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION OF THE AND THE
ADVOCATE TO TWELVE ALL.
EXPANDING THE CURRENT
CONGREGATE PLEASE PEOPLE CARRY
OUT OF SCHOOL ALLOW HUNDREDS OF
PUBLICATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
TO KEEP SERVING AND LOCAL. AND
JUST BECAUSE ACTUALLY.
OFFICIALS AGAIN I NOT KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE BILL TO
MEMBERS AND I GRATITUDE TO
LEGISLATORS STAKEHOLDERS TO
BOARD I **** PROFITS MARGINS
HOW THE REASONS I AM. STRONGLY
THE COURT IT WOULD BE OF AND WE
RESPECT URGE THOUGHT. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TO SOME
WILL COME TO THE ROOMS IF
THERE'S ANY IN TE CAN ROOM- TO
EXPRESS A SUPPORT AS ON A BEEF
KNOWS. A SINGLE INCOME FOR WILL
CHECK OVER FOR ROOM FOR. WITH
THE SCISSORS NOBODY THERE WILL
GO TO THE MODERATOR IMMODERATE
ALASKA TO PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES ON AB FIFTEEN
OH SIX AND PLEASE LET US KNOW
THE NUMBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN OH SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE HAVE NO- LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS IDENTIFIED
ON THIS BILL SO WE'RE GONNA ASK
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WISHES TO EXPRESS IN
OPPOSE POSITION ON AB FIFTEEN
OH SIX PLEASE COME FORWARD C.
KNOWN COMPORT WILL CHECK YOUR
FOR ROOM. THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY
MODERATOR. I WAS THE ONE MORE
TIME TO CHECK THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THIS TIME
FOR OPPOSITION TESTIMONY ON AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU MR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IT WAS JUST BECAUSE OPPOSITION
OF AB FIFTEEN OH SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO WE
HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR A WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE LET ME JUST SAY-
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
A LITTLE FACETIOUS GIVEN THAT
YOU WERE THE LAST TWO BILLS-
THE TODAY- YOU KNOW YOU. KNOW I
CAN GET AWAY WITH THAT BECAUSE
OF OUR LONGSTANDING
PROFESSIONAL RELATIONSHIP BUT I
DO WANT TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE
FOR- FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
DIVE INTO EXTREME NEGOTIATIONS
ON A BILL LIKE THIS. A TO GET
IT TO US TO TRY TO GET
RESOLUTION OF A THORNY ISSUE.
AT THIS TIME AND- I WILL TURN
TO OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TELL TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES HERE FROM THE US. A
MEMBERSHIP. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
FOR THIS MEASURE- ALTHOUGH I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE FULL
REPEAL OF EIGHTY FIVE AND THE
RESTORATION OF ECONOMIC FREEDOM
FOR HARD WORKING INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE THREE ADDITIONAL YEARS
A REALLY FOR NEWSPAPER
DISTRIBUTORS FOR THESE REASONS
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. AND WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT LEGISLATION THAT
PROVIDES FOR THE ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY AND INDEPENDENCE OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THE COMMENDED
BY SHARED SENATE RUSSELL I WILL
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE
MISTER CHAIR- BUT I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE THE- AUTHORED
THANK THE AUTHOR. OF WE HAVE TO
STAY ON TOP OF THIS ON TO MANY
INDUSTRIES AND SECTORS BOB SO
USED TO. VIOLATING THE LAW WHEN
IT CAME COMES TO THE- STATUS OF
EMPLOYEES AND INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND- YOU'RE TAKING
SOME STRONG STEPS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO IT THE RIGHT WAY-
AND- WORDS FINE THEN IT WORKS
TO BE AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR. BUT DON'T USE THAT
AS A COVER FOR SOMETHING ELSE
SO. I'M GLAD YOU'RE GETTING
INTO THE WEEDS OF IT. FIGURE
EIGHTY FIVE WITHOUT WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW SO THANK YOU. I
COULDN'T BELIEVE IT YES MEMBERS
SURE LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU WILL COME BACK TO THE
AUTHOR FOR ANY CLOSING
STATEMENT I'D LIKE TO MAKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
THINK I'LL BE SEEING YOU ON A
COUPLE BILLS ASSEMBLY HOUSINGS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND
IN KIND TO THE GOOD NATURED-
ASPECT OF A- LOT OF THE BACK
AND FORTH WE HAVE WITH BETWEEN
OUR HOUSES BUT I WILL TELL YOU.
THAT YOU KNOW TO CENTER THE
ROSSES POINT- THE REALITY IS
LAST COUPLE YEARS URBAN
EXTENSIONS WITH WITH NO DATA
COLLECTION WITH NO FOR BUT I
PERSONALLY SEE IT AS A LOST
OPPORTUNITY HOW THIS COUPLE
YEARS WILL BE REALLY COULD HAVE
DUG DEEP SO I'M VERY GRATEFUL
TO THE NEWSPAPER OF THE-
NEWSPAPER ASSOCIATION- OR THE-
THE- NEW. PUBLISHERS SO ARE.
FOR REALLY GOOD THIS YEAR I
THINK THAT REALLY DOES THE
BEGIN THIS IS NOT THE END. THIS
IS NOT TO HAVE FOR US TO OF GET
THE INFORMATION. THAT'S
APPROPRIATE TO DETERMINE WHAT
KIND OF LONG TERM- EITHER
OBLIGATIONS ARE REGULATIONS OR
AFP STATUS. THREE ONE OF FOOD
DID WE WANT TO PUT ON THIS
INDUSTRY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE INDUSTRY AND
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE ESPECIALLY OF. NEWS
MEDIA THE THESE LAST FEW YEARS
AND SO WE WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL
OF THAT. BUT WE ALWAYS WANT TO
BE RESPECTFUL TO WORKERS AS
WELL BUT IT DOES GIVE US A PATH
FORWARD FOR THAT AND SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU. AND THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND I
AND I SPECIAL I THINK YOUR
STAFF YOUR LABOR COMMITTEE
STAFF THAT'S- NOT JUST ON THIS
BILL- BUT I THINK OVER THE-
PAST FEW MONTHS HAS WORKED
REALLY WELL WITH OUR LABOR
COMMITTEES AFTER LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUED. COLLABORATION AND
COOPERATION AND. SUPPORT OF ONE
ANOTHER. IN THE MONTHS AND
YEARS AHEAD. THE ESPECT HE HAS
FOR I BOUGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBER SO- DO HAVE A MOVE. THE
BY A PLAYER BY SHOULD- CENTER
WHICH WILL GO. AND WILL HAS
CONSOLED PLEASE TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE. SHANICE TO PASS THE
FIRST BE RE TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PROTESTING. HI
BUT AS THE I. R. CHAU BOOK I
PLEDGE ABOAGYE WRESTLE. THE
REST SO I LAYERED HI THERE I
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN AYE. ON
THE UNANIMOUS VOTE THE BILLS
OUT THANK YOU. WE ARE AT THE
END OF OUR GENDER- AND LET ME
JUST SAY BEFORE WE FORMALLY
ADJOURNED THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE- WE APPRECIATE TO ALL
TESTIMONY WE HEARD TODAY FOR
THOSE THAT ARE STICKING AROUND
FOR THE GERMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS
USUAL FOR OF PUTTING TOGETHER
AN ORDERLY MEETING TODAY- AND
TAKE YOUR ROOM FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION AND THANK YOU FOR
THE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WE HAVE
IN THE ROOM. FROM SERGEANTS AND
OTHERS KEEPING AN ORDERLY
PRESENCE TODAY WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE
COOPERATION- WE HAVE INCLUDED
THESE GENDER IN THE LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE MEETING OF
JULY TWELFTH. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IS HEREBY ADJOURN THANK YOU.